and you know yany will tell us about an
exciting line of work which connects
crypto and metacomplexity and so this is
really a perfect fit for this Workshop
in the program
and so yeah
yeah
thank you for introducing me and uh hi
everybody I'm very excited to be here uh
to talk about say like okay basically to
give like a simple tutorial on like
cryptography and like a Commodore
capacity or like metal capacity and then
this is based on joint work with uh
Rafael pass who's over there my amazing
advisor so
um this talk is going to be
right it's into two parts
and so in part one uh I'm going to as
mention a tutorial on like metal compass
and cryptography and it marked part two
I will talk about like a well take like
a win-win perspective and to look at
like the results we get like a in part
one and this surprisingly like we get
like some results like a from this View
and
yeah well okay it's like
after this is like after something new
like after three years like or like so
yeah to me it's like a really surprising
and okay so if uh so there would be like
something new for like in a part two for
those who like have a thing like to my
talk like before so uh let me start with
like a tutorial
so
um
today uh we're going to focus on like
the notion of Huawei functions
which is like the genius notion proposed
by different Hammer is 76 and I guess
like we all know it's like a really
basic notion uh for cryptography
so what is one function uh well I guess
we all know it's like something easy to
compute but it's really hard to invert
so
um let me also recall like the formal
definition for bits so for any function
f we say that it's like one way if for
any
PPT attacker a well like given me like a
random input X like of lens n and I like
like y equal f of x
and I ask like the probability that the
attacker a I'll input like the stream y
finds like a pre-image of f of x is at
most a negligible amount and I want to
highlight hear that well like this
distribution over Y is actually defined
by this one function now
and as we oh no like wave function is
really like a very very important notion
in cryptography and it's like both
necessary and sufficient basically for
the whole world of private key crypto
well including like a private key
encryption like prg prf we have like
signature if if we have one function
then we compute like authentication
scheme like coin tossing scheme
commitments games well basically like a
really beautiful world here
the weather where function exists is
really the most like unequivocally
the most important problem in
cryptography
and as we can see well like if we have a
function we can build like this whole
like a beautiful world but as we shall
be like very soon and when it comes to
well like where the wire function exists
like we really like know like a very few
about this
and well to I have to be honest like so
um notable like crypto schemes including
like pke or like obvious transfer and
obscation uh they are not included in
this list but well the point here is
like to do crypto even with those like a
powerful Primitives you still need like
web function
so the question here is like weather
where function exists
okay what do we know and well like a
simple observation tells us if we are
able to prove like a y function exists
unconditionally this would give us like
a proof of MP is not equal to P well so
like proving it unconditionally exists
seems to be like too much to hope for
so like also in a similar paper by
different Helmer they propose like the
Holy Grail of groupography is basically
to show like the converse is true or to
prove that we can paste one function on
the assumption that MP is not equal to p
and again unfortunately this is like
still a very very hard like a very very
challenged like problem and they we have
like many results of this but of course
she's like
both all of them are like most of them
are just like a negative result or like
a black ball separation
so in the absence of the Holy growth
well we need cryptography to protect our
privacy over the Internet so we really
need like wire functions
so what you would do like people have
discovered well those amazing
computational problems whose hardness
will like enable us to uh get
cryptography so we have like fact the
fracturing problem the discrete
logarithm problem and more recently that
has problems and in practice we also
have like heuristic construction such as
the S Shar AES
oh great
and so far like those are not broken
but the question here is like for how
long like how long do they last
as mikali says like in 88 well like
cryptographers stop and sleep well okay
why because we know like if we have like
content computers then we know well
Factory and discrete logarithm problems
are actually easy and can be solved by
like a quantum computer in polynomial
time
so like the central question like for
the part way of this talk
is that does there exist well like at
some like very natural average case hard
problem like who's like harness
characterizes the existing software
functions
so if we get like such a problem then
kind of great we if we want to like
reduce wave function we can just focus
our attention like basically on the
harness of this problem and this is
going to be without loss of generality
we provide like a affirmative answer to
this question and we gave like a
characterization of my functions uh so
basically we show that for like any
polynomial t i one functions exists if
and only if it is like T time bounded
comogo compacity is mildly hard on
average
so as we shall see like very soon this
like tea time boundary
it's really like a classical notion and
has been started since the 60s
and also like the mildly like average
case harness we need here is also like
standard hardness notion for average
case hardness in the literature
okay so well let us introduce the notion
of compastic
yeah like
it's like very exciting to introduce
like metal compressor again in this
Workshop like
um great so like you so
um
the question here is like we have the
following two string like the first
three is like one two three something
and the seconds which is like one server
three blah blah blah and the question is
like which of the two strings is more
random
and if you look at those two strings
like the answer seems to be like obvious
well like Apparently one two three is
not but like it's the second one like I
don't know what it is it should be
random
but when you think about it it's like a
bit tricky to argue like why the second
point is like more random because if you
look at uniform distribution they have
equal probability Mass
okay so as suggested by komogo we like
instead we should look at well the lens
of the shortest program that's generates
this string X
and let you know this like value by K of
x
and it this notion turns out to be well
like an amazing motion
capture like to measure how much
Randomness like a individual string has
and
I also have like a picture here and uh
as we can see it's like a pretty
beautiful and I love it and like
arguably it's like a beautifulness comes
from like it the fact that it has like
more capacity so
yes
it's a nice picture
and as you can see if I put a random
picture here like it's going to be like
some noise here it's not going to be
beautiful
[Laughter]
so like yeah like how like like how
short this program can be if we want to
generate like this picture but we know
this must be a way but it's not clear
right because
okay so
I we can probably fix like a universal
treatment you and we are looking for
like the lens of the shortest program Pi
uh which consists of first like a
description of a true matching and
seconds
um the contents on the input tape W
um such that when being simulators on
the user Universal tour machine like
this program M on input W should like
outputs the string X and I want to
remark here that well like the most like
the most common complaints like about
capacity is well basically this
Universal true version you like or you
can ask well can we find like another
Universal stream rushing that like makes
the description shorter and in this talk
this doesn't really matter like any of
your favorite true version kind of fit
here and it's it's easier to just like
think of like python here so here like
any programs in this talk are just
python programs and everything will like
work printed by
um
[Laughter]
and Okay so
we know like the notion of commercial
compacity well has a lot of amazing
applications well you can really improve
like a like a lot of theorem using this
notion like for example like codico's
incompetence theorem like in addition
can also prove like density of primes
and there are like more theorems you can
prove
but like unfortunately this notion is
like a uncomputable and uncomputed
motion are typically not very
interesting
so we need to do something to make it
computable
so we instead look at like the
time-bounded variants of a Commodore
capacity so instead of looking at like
all programs well we just restrict our
attention to like this program that runs
within like a certain running time down
so given me like a running time Bounty I
can Define where basically the same
thing but within time T of length of x
and as we can see like if we have like a
running time bounce then this notion
becomes like computable
and
the question here is whether like KT
superscript C can be efficiently
computed when T is like a polynomial
so well this as mentioned this is really
like a classical question and there has
been studied in the Soviets Union since
the 60s and also like by more modernly
by hardman's sister and Co in the 80s
and as we can see it's like closely
related to like the minimum so-called
like a minimal circuit size problem
so here basically if you like take a
different computation although so here
we are looking at the Victoria machines
and if you if you love circuits then
there's like a minimal circuits a
capacitive variance and so
I want to mention here that like this uh
like this question of whether KC can be
efficient computed it's like actually a
meta comparative problem
so why this is a meta capacity basically
Katie asks for like a capacity of a
fixed string and we are asking can this
like a KGB efficient computed this is
like a complexity of a capacity of the
string so uh this will refer to uh meta
capacity this is where like the name uh
comes from
okay and
now let me introduce like a the notion
of a average case partners that we rely
on
so somewhat intriguingly even like in
the 60s they have like this notion has
been studied and they call it like a
frequential version
so the question here is basically it
does there exist an algorithm that
computes like KT of x basically for a
large fraction of x's
and well like a simple observation here
it's like
this KT
well it seems to be like as mentioned
pretty like hard to compute but it can
be actually like approximated with the
ink an addition factor of log n with
like a pretty decent probability one
minus one over n
and well the algorithm here is like
really simple which is outputs like n
where n is well the length of my input
string
okay let's like stop a little bit and
see like why they say outputting and
heuristic it works pretty well
so let's look at those strings on which
like my outputting and here is your
thoughts
and because it fails that I know uh it
has well it couldn't have like couple
capacity larger than a minus and Plus
login because well like for any for any
string like think about like the Python
program like like print together with
like this string so basically you you
just need to pay like the lens of like a
command prints to print the string so
the comor compass is going to be
something like M plus of one at most
no so if they say my simple curiosity
fails then it has to fill on like those
strings with common compasses smaller
than mine's login
and we know there are only two to the
well like minus a minus log in such many
programs and therefore like my simple
heuristic oil only sell on such
um the output of such programs and
therefore I was success with like pretty
decent probability
so
but not really that's a note that here
the simple Jurassic will only succeed
a uniform a uniform distribution right
because so now we can ask
like a more General version so if I have
like instead of uniform I have like a
efficient example of a distribution D
then does there exists an algorithm like
computers kg of X over like X samples
from this distribution and by efficient
computable description well it's just
like can be sampled by probably the true
machine and basically like those in
cryptography like and in qgm will Define
like a efficient computable distribution
um
so let me give like the definition of a
average case harness we need here so we
said that's KT it's like mildly hot on
average with respect to some
distribution D or if there exists like a
polynomial P such that no PP here yes
PPT heuristic can compute like KT with
probability well one minus one over PL
of n over like random string sample from
d for infancy Mania or like
alternatively like every attacker will
fail on like a small fraction while
we'll probably fraction
so this is like the a harness assumption
we need
and say so uh please like ask questions
like feel free to stop me to ask when
you have a question
so um as it gets to our like main
theorem in lp20 so we showed that well
the following are equivalent and first
where functions exist and second there
exists some point number two such that
KT is mildly hot on average over uniform
distribution
well if you look at it it's like really
a pretty nice hard assumption so KT's
natural notion multi heart on average
like standard notion of Advocates
hardness and uniform distribution it's
like arguably the most nature
distribution
here is exact location
and well I will mention like
approximation very soon okay because of
the approximation was easy so
um
this is one this is only a uniform
distribution
so well first of all these gifts well
really what we want like a nature
traveling characterizing the visibility
of like basic tasks in cryptography like
if this problem is hard then we have
like prg if you have commitments I like
all those stuff it's like great it's
like what we were looking for and say so
let me get catch you like this
approximation version so actually like
our proof like it showed like an
independent result for with respect to
KT capacity so remember like the now the
hot on average like definition I gave it
really says like if you want to say
break this hardness you need to like
find like a like we're roughly speaking
a attacker that succeeds with like one
minus negligible probability
so yeah even like even if it's hard like
oh with hobby it's like easy with
probability like one man's one of them
this is like not enough to deduce that
this is like a not average case hard
so yeah it's still like a meaningful
question like asking whether KT is like
login like it's hard to approximate
within like all Vlog and Factor so in
fact like going through our proof of
this theorem like we obtain like
something it's like a statement of KC
capacity without crypto but using like
ID like using or like by going through
like those crypto objects so we showed
that well if KT is like mildly hard or
hard on average to compute exactly
if you assume so then you also get like
hardness with with respect to
approximation so we also get like Katie
is like about the heart on average tool
all of Logan approximate and they of
course like a uh the second kind of
trivia imply like the first statement
so this is like a very like intriguing
to me because
this is like a statement with no crypto
but we only know how to prove this like
by going through like crypto and then
going back so like
like arguably there's like something
like there this is for the uniform
distribution or yeah this is for the
University so back to the definition of
smiley yeah
so iris is like exists if it's like my
madly harder is if it's like mildly hard
if exists like some polynomial such that
nobody succeeds with probability better
than one minus one over p
so or like in other words like to break
this uh you really need like a algorithm
that succeed with like one minus
negligible probability
yeah this is it exactly yeah compute it
exactly
and or of course it also makes sense if
you define like an approximation version
like
uh yes good question and I guess I will
get to that like for instance here
Okay so
uh let me hear a remarks uh mention some
like a early connections between y
functions and meta capacity and we are
definitely not the first one who kind of
discovered this a connection so uh this
dates back to like a raspberry rootage
and their nature proof so they observed
that say if a while function exists then
basically meta capacity or like KT
capacity should be worse case hard and
well the idea is basically you can you
should be able to break like a prg using
like a worst case algorithm for KC and
the converse Direction however like if
KT is hard then do we get one function
this is like not known and also this
observation is also like kind of not
enough for us because we're going to
show like why functions implies KT is
like mildly hot on average and this is
going to be a lot harder to do
and also like a very recent result by
since I rahulan like he showed that like
under like a new conjecture m6p is like
airlessly a hard on average if and only
one functions exists and as many since
this mcsp mineral circuit size problem
is like really close to closely
connected with k2kt but in conscious our
result is like an unconditional
characterization
it's something like if you actually like
if oxidation with white function exists
then well function exists it's like a
seems like we seems to be very far from
proving this conjecture but if one
function exists it's like privilege
yeah oh this is like another notion of
average case hardness where like you
need like you need to know it's when you
like make a mistake so here we are
consider like a you can output like you
when you make a mistake you can just
like output like amateur things but in
errorless average case part is like you
can only output like a single bot or you
have to be you or you have to Output the
correct answer
uh uh yes but it's like under under
conduction yes
[Music]
um
I think so because well like yes
so anyway it's going to be like probably
not probably One Direction follows from
Russell yes One Direction follows power
directions
okay so let's quickly videos
So today we're going to show like a
shortness of Pepsi please uh what exists
of web function and let me also mention
here that's the other direction uh in
which we show like one functions that
implies harness of KT
um it's going to be like the harder
direction direction in which like we
followed like the nature proof Paradigm
but we have to go through like a a new
notion of a prg uh we call like a
conditionally secure engine pressure in
prg and I'm not going to like talk about
it in this talk so
let us jump into like our Construction
so here we want to show that say
assuming like KC is like now the harder
average than why functions exist
and we know that deduced by a function
it suffices to show like a weak wire
functions exists and what is a weak one
function I guess like you all know it's
it's kind of like a mildly hot average
version of The Wire function which will
just like ask for mild hardness and by
the famous like harness application
letter we know well if a weak while
function exists then we get a wire
function
So today we're just going to construct a
weak wire function so let us jump into
our construction so
um so first before I sketch out my
construction I'm going to fix like a
universal currency so let's see be like
a constant such as for any string X KT
of X is like Atmos say length of X plus
C so as mentioned just think about like
the lens of common prints for like
python programs and now our like a y
function is going to take like a a
random string Pi print Pi Prime of lens
like n plus C and also like a random
index like think of it as an integer
from like one to n plus C and which
takes like a log and plus three bits to
encode
so like the first step in our function
is to kind of truncate like this very
long stream Pi Prime to well like this
first type it's uh prefix so we denote
like PI app so basically here is like Pi
Prime and I will only look at like the
first one to iPads and we just remove
like the rest of it
and we're going to interpret like this
prefix pi as a program
and we can't we run this program for
like TL fan steps we're like T is my
runtime bands and we'll let y denote the
output of this program pi
and finally we're going to outputs like
the render index I like concatenate with
say my output y
and this completes the construction of
our function f
okay so let's just let us really show
that this is really one way assuming
like I harness of KC so we'll assume for
a contradiction right so then assume for
assume like somebody in like somebody
can invert it with probability like one
man's negligible and we want to kind of
construct like an algorithm that
computes like KT of X with like a
women's negligroll probability and this
is going to be a contradiction
so if we have inverted two iron function
like how do we compute like a KT
capacity
so
our heuristic is like also pretty like
straightforward like a given me like a
string Y and my goal here is to compute
the KT capacity of what
so what do we do like we first like try
all possible like I from like one all
the way to M plus C so we try like I
equals one I equals two so like for each
eye
we basically run the attacker
like
um basically we asked the attacker to
invert the image like I concatenate with
y
and if this attacker succeeds well it
should give me like a program Pi of lens
I
and such as this Pi after you run it it
will generate like my input y
and of course it doesn't always exist so
we have to check like whether Pi in bit
like outputs My Stream why with MTF and
steps and finally I would I will output
like the smallest eye on which like the
above check pass
so well this is just like so you can
just think of like a given like string
why I try like a one with I2 with like a
three with I until I get like a a
anything like a from the inverter
so let's try to see why this is like a
good algorithm for kg and
intuitively if this attacker succeeds
say with pop if you want then
uh-huh
yes
whoever is like stand for rather index
and you truncate according to your like
index and you see like you run with like
a program for the open Snap and you
output basically the index together with
these outputs so
if you want to compute like AC compress
it just try even like why just try all
possible I am like seeing when it's when
it succeeds in inverting this function
yeah
and say everybody good
yeah definitely it was good the price
like you first invert the get high Prime
and I and then yes yes
Okay so
like intuitively well if this attacker
succeeds with the probability one then
in some sense like
uh if I is like too small there's like a
no no program that computes like that
can produce like my stream why and if
the index I is like exactly the
commercial capacity of Y then we know
there is going to be some program
outputing why and because like my
inverter succeeds was very like with
property one say then we can we should
be able to like find this program
like however
the problem here is really like we don't
get like a a inverter that success with
probability one
and if you look at this we are actually
fitting our inverter a like the round
distribution
so
let us zoom into like this question so
in a way of functioning experiments
where like this inverter is guaranteed
to work
we know that's like I is a random like a
random index from like one to n plus C
and here Y is an output of a random
program of let's I
however like in this KT experiments
where we really want to show like hey it
works
this like I it's kind of we really want
to show it works um like the exact like
Commodore capacity of Y and what is like
more problematic is it's like a
distribution over y it comes from like a
uniform distribution
and like alternatively if you think
about it is like if you have like
somebody succeeds in like say one
function experiments and if you look at
like outputs of random program then
given like a random program is like
pretty likely that this program is going
to be invalid and it's like possible
that well like my inverter will just
succeeds on those like invalid programs
and I didn't learn anything from out of
it
so there's like no reason to believe
that if somebody succeeds there we can
just use it it's like here
um but like by using like accounting
arguments we can actually show that well
this these two distribution are actually
like not so far away like in what we
call like a relative distance
so let me sketch like a the proof behind
this so assume for Simplicity that this
attacker a is like deterministic
if not you can fix the random tape and
it's like a approach to deal with this
and let us consider substring why I wish
like H filth so like in a case
experiments say like my heuristic fails
on some string why and we know here like
y has probability Mass like roughly two
to the minus l in like because like a
uniform random string well hits y with
pop it's like two to the minus yeah
and now let's look at
um
what happens to Y like in this well
function experiments so we'll add We'll
add W equals like equal KT of Y and we
observe that for like for my heroesic
Edge to fell on white like of my
inverter must fell on W concatening with
Y so if my inverse exists then it wants
like it will output the correct answer
so it must spell
so and if it must tell them the
probability that this like pair Wy
will be sampled with in where function
uh experiments with probability well
like first we need like a one over n
plus C for like a random index I to hit
like my KT comparison w
and after that we know that y here has
there is like a because Casey comparison
why it's just W so there it exists some
like machine of less W that will output
the string why
and therefore it has probability Mass
like and Y Over N plus uh well over n
plus c times two juice minus W in the Y
function experiments
and well apparently this probability
Mass is like at least say one over and
times two to three minus l so let's say
if our heuristic Edge fails with like
some noticeable probability like a one
over p
then we know that like our attacker
inverter a must also fell with
probability well like well P divided by
L which is like a not negligible
but we know like our attackers succeed
with like why my negotiable probability
so therefore like my heuristic will also
succeed with environments like Drop
ability and this is like indeed good
attacker so uh which is a contradiction
it's going to stop here like a bit and
any questions to uh construction and say
you have like a one-line intuition so
what is the what is the side doing for
us
um
yes
what are you doing I'm trying to sit
down at the high level you're saying
this and it's kind of a guess
complexity
is right right that's uh
but do you want to think of it yeah you
can say you can think well it's just
trying all possible ice
and
it's like a standard where you like have
you like reduce like a
sound problem of like a some like say
like a like Max like um uh say like a
minimum in Japan stats too like it's the
institutional murder right so you just
like you you have like an instance you
just have like those uh like a kind of
like but here it's like an index here
and
how do I just get an attention
no no of course of course you saw the
eye doesn't make any sense
I like it I'm trying to understand kind
of the high level intuition here which
is that like
you take this eye this eye is supposedly
the eye you're interested in is the
correct eye that gives you the correct
kind of uh
and once you hit that
is what kind of helps you to get the
reduction tomorrow
yes yeah
and essentially we're we're kind of
proving that it's like a kind of both
like a useful like a eye together with
like programs so basically it was like a
catchy witness is going to be it's going
to be like dance they might be here for
example you're looking at random skin as
you are looking at the prefix of size
random if you change the one function to
be left upper positive
you have just considered a random string
of length up to n and you wouldn't work
with that
um
so you have two parts of the input yes
exactly and and I yeah
overall it extracts the length High
prefix which is a random bit string yeah
so now suppose I design a new one with
function
uh domain is not bit string Supply
up to n
here
yes like if you switch to like
like if you have like a of strings to
like less up to high yeah you need to
make sure that like you sample like like
you you stand for each of the lens like
with like equal probability because I'm
not gonna I'm just saying the Illusion
for the original what's the function
yes but then for each different
influence you will have like a sale then
it's not no longer like a uniform
distribution so you're going to have
like a well over and probability you
sample from say random three of L over
two and also whatever and probability in
San Jose
so it's like not going to be uniform so
I guess like the best way to describe
this distribution is also still like
taking I and and students truncation
distance okay
and I do want to mention here that's it
Q is actually like it's actually not
very tight here right so if you look at
the probability
um on one hand we have like one over n
times like two to the minus W and the
only thing we want is just like one over
n times like two to the N so there is a
gap and the physical this is going to be
helpful like in the second part of this
talk
okay so uh let me move on to like
summarize a bit of like a those exciting
results along like a work with like math
compassions and crypto okay
I think your definition is the pipe just
take the first time this but the linear
heuristic when you check you you are not
trucking you are using the pie oh right
well like the Spy you knows like well Pi
after 20 like pipeline so you do like
yeah
and
we actually prove that if you like to
get like a while sub axle wire function
you only need to consider like sublinear
average case hardness if you consider
like some like a come over complexity
problem
and we also have like a well functions
from like an X complete language well if
an X completes language is like average
case harder then we get
it's like a a hard with respect to
algorithm that runs in time like and to
the point one and say part
um
it's like a mildly hard on average like
our new programs that run in 10 to the
point one time uh like a yeah like
mildly Hollow average with respect to
algorithms while saying like subbing
your time or like square roots and time
and
we also gets like a web functions from
like empty complete language so if you
consider like average case hardness
sorry I'm I'm so confused about this
submarinity yeah
one bit of the accelerator kind of bit
by bit is that kind of the
yeah it doesn't get like the input of
the whole instance but you have to still
decide the problem
that's enough to get one stop expansion
on the function yeah this is like a
bizarre week like yeah harness or
something right because you don't get
read the whole input like how can you
like it apparently it's not hard like in
worst case so you have Ram accessive
input like when you talk about it it's
actually it's enough to prove with too
much in Access but it's a gap version
now it's not the uh August including it
it's a hardness of deciding what is big
or small
yes
there's like a like a language like a
relative like it's like a conditional
version of a commercial fantastic and we
saw that it is MP hard and if you
consider like the average case harness
of that language and then you get like a
y function and it's like a and it's the
average case harness of that problem
like characterizes the exists of man
function so really uh to it's also like
a necessary and sufficient to kind of
show like a worst case for average case
production to that problem if we want to
get like one functions from what's his
harness of MP but like it really only
functions through the workspace is also
empty complete right yes it's kind of a
similar connection but to a problem
that's like more natural and just say
Okay
um yeah this is like a much more things
like you can hopeful like if you have
like an actual problem like
um you can hope for like worst case
average case induction which like you
couldn't for like archery like a thing
and yes there are like uh like we
believe there's like a
there are really like benefits you get
from didn't like nature can you do this
with any sampling hard distribution for
the language or does this specific yeah
this is going to be what I I'm going to
talk about seeing in part two
sometimes so I also mentions like
adequate work by like a planning and
Rahul like the shows like we can also
characterize like nc01 functions using
common complexity
and there's like worries out which as
you can see I don't have time to go
through it okay okay let me try to like
wrap up like my part two in 15 minutes
like okay
um so I'm going to take like a win-wing
perspective and to look at like the
results we gets like from part one so
recall that in part one we showed like
web functions is equivalent to K2 being
like how the color average
and there are two interpretations of a
this result
so first
this proves that the web functions exist
if KT is mildly Corner average so
basically says that if we want to deduce
one function great we can study hardness
of a KC capacity
and and interpretion two would be like
well this is a win-win situation
so you know where we situation we
usually get some like something like
either like this primitive secure or we
get like an algorithmic breakthrough so
here we get like either way functions
exists or like we obtain an algorithm
that say computers KC of X or even it
actually finds a creative witness of x
if you recall like the heuristic
so what does it mean it mean by like
well it's easy to compute KT
so if like finding cases it's easy then
like obviously we can do like Optimal
file compression and here what is more
interesting well okay I'm be I'm going
to be like a really politic here and
uh you can do like all kinds of Razor
um what's the consequence of for our
campus razor again like I'm going to be
like really poetic and so if finding K2
with is easy then and I climbed it well
like science Discovery is easy
if you believe all Cam's razor so what
does all cameras say he says well the
simplest explanation is going like
mostly likely going to be the choice and
well this is like a arguably like the
prevailing like belief in our science
Community today and so if you believe
like oh camps razor simply is it like
the best like
yes we need to assume like nature is
like computational funded of course we
do
[Laughter]
yeah like it's already like good enough
for me if you say like we can paste my
function on like harness of a like
classical science Discovery and anyway
so you can imagine like well if we have
like a Argus and finding Katie witness
like we can just crack like a bunch of
data and we're looking for like a
hypothesis that explains this data and
what is this hypothesis well all cancer
reasons is it's like the sh like the
shortest one and this is exactly finding
like the combo capacity of my data and
of course it's like caviar caveats like
we need to assume like a nature is
efficient and we need to assume like
collecting data is easy
and however it is like another important
like a missing piece here
just namely
if we look at like our theorem so what
we really get is like we get like a
Katie algorithm that works over its
uniform distributions
so if you plug in like my like Poetic
like a paradigm it's going to give like
science over uniform random strings
which is like typically not very
interesting like who cares about like
science over universe
so today like the question part two is
like can we do better
so can we say can we make this like over
like practical instances
and
and our results like in the second part
is is that basically you can you we are
able to achieve this by kind of do like
doing science over like a efficiently
sampled instances
and we saw that
okay
and we saw that well like if we consider
like a probabilistic variance of a kitty
which we call like a pkt and I'm going
to introduce this notion well maybe not
because I only have like 10 minutes just
like now just think of like pkt as like
KT and the following are equivalents so
first my functions exist and second well
there exists like some sample
Distribution on which like this pkt is
mildly harder which and the third a
uniform over uniform distribution like
this pkt notion is mildly hot average so
we basically show like an equivalence of
all these three things
or like a uniform reference stream
so basically if first there's like a CRS
and you can pick your shortage program
after seeing
and it's basically the same here
is a capacity assumption is going to be
the same as like KT but well of course
we're doing additive factor of our login
it's going to fix that
and so
um so let's just pretend like TKD is
just 7 SKT and so if we look at
Bluetooth and please one whoa it's this
is just like a strong women situation
right because we say like either way
function exists or for like any
efficiently samples to relax we can find
like the short program like progress
that produce X like efficiently and this
allows us like and if and like uh
efficient approach implementing like all
countries it's like what we want in like
my I like Polytech description
with the type of probability does so you
don't know yes
but you need to be careful it's like a
safe situation here algorithms
um
then you're going to uh
seems like it this is like it's going to
give something weaker right it's going
to like stop asking like notification
anymore so
okay great so then that because like I'm
like I'm kind of hiding from the like
pkt from you let's let me do it like
formally so we can show like under
standard driven meditation assumption
basically if you replace like PKG by KT
all this like three will still hold and
the Assumption here is like a the
capacity Class E doesn't have like an
image open non-determine Society like a
sub exercise circuit and let me mention
this is like a standard uh capacity
assumption and it implies like a mp uh
am equals MP the randomizes like am to
MK
and they
yes
exactly so it doesn't really follow from
this assumption but like by going
through our proof we can actually show
this like with like exact compute like
fear is like it's exact like everything
is like exact
okay because I'm running out of time so
I'm going to skip this properties the
notion just think about it's like CRS KT
and also I want to mention here if we
look just look at like a bullets two and
pull it three well this basically says
if pkt is hard under like sound sample
with distribution then it's hard over
uniform distribution
or like alternatively like uniform
distribution is the hardest distribution
for pkt this is like very surprising
like how can like uniform distribution
be like the hardest and let me mention
very quickly here that the impact is an
11 in my in it might say like the show
that's if there's like languaging MP
this is going to be like another
language L Prime
such as L is like hot on average with
respect to sound distribution there's
like an L Prime another language that is
however with respect to uniform
distribution and well this is not the
same language and L Prime you get is
like a unfortunately not very nature and
our result kind of is like the first
like non-algebraic language within MP
such that like a hardness with respect
to like any sample in place harness with
respect to uniform and of course like
you can say like discrete log also
sensifies this due to like randomizer
self-reducibility but while such
languages are like really rare in within
like MP
and I guess I have to mention this like
very really reasons elegant work by
who I and who else and the high Lane so
they showed that basically like under
the randomization Edition assumption
like why function is equivalent to KT
being hard to like Omega login or
Postmates with respect to the sound
sample of a distribution so here we only
require like hardness of like solving
the exact version of KC and I want to
mention here that this is not only like
a matter of like approximation Gap this
is like significance in the sense that
well if you look at KT it's going to be
easy to Omega log n approximate over
uniform distribution so just outputting
m
and
by going through like their proof like
you show that well any distribution that
is hard this distribution is going to be
like a wave function so like
unfortunately like it doesn't tell us
much like if we want to build like a web
function from scratch but like I really
like adequate work which kind of
inspires our our result so I don't
really have time go going into like
proof so like really high level idea
which we're we're going to use like the
same construction and by observe like a
like this like this like is the fact
that it's not tight that I mentioned and
we can actually like show switch to
uniform switch like uniform distribution
until like more General Distribution and
how General it is like okay by like a a
by like a results say recent results are
coding theorem this is going to be like
a really General like an example
distribution but I I unfortunately I
don't really have like enough time to go
through like the proof but the idea is
here like this is not tight so you can
do something better and this is really
powerful
and you step two Falls from like a uh
the reasons uh result on coming through
so like a summary like very nice
situation and also get first language
that means like uniform is like the
complete distribution okay let me use
like my last two minutes to briefly
sketch like the approach towards like
excluding passy line so passy lines
means like a world of uh impact else is
five words uh in which MP is a higher
average but there is no one function so
to exclude this world we need to show
like one function but when it's your
show one function from MP is hard on
average and here's like a uh like a a
tentative approach so if MP is harder
average then we're not like set is
harder of it average under some
distribution and if we are able to show
like pkt is hard on average over some
distribution then we're done because by
what we have in today in place value
function
and you probably you will be like
confused like how does it mean like what
does it mean like that is hard on
average in place like pkt's horror which
and like a key observation here is that
actually you only need to to show like
this you only need to prove like empty
hardness of PPT which is like a really
like a important problem like in method
complexity well the basic idea is like
if that is hard on some distribution you
can use a reduction to Define another
distribution over pkt which is also hard
and arguably this is like seems to be
even necessary even assuming I oh like
uh see Highlands Target it is happening
okay so and there's some technicality
here which I don't have time to cover
and but I also want to mention like this
like a recent result basically showing
uh it's like this is not a problem and
so we are getting closer
and say
no it's something it suffices to like
ampere harness like he'll say if you
prove like empty harness you can use
this reduction
like say that is hard on average over
some distribution this gives like a
distribution of which like set is hard
you just plug in this reduction and well
like it's a set formula you get here you
plug in reduction you get like a PKD
instance and this is going to show like
a pkt is also harder on average with
under some sample distribution
production right yeah yeah we need like
a copy reduction yes
good points if we can progress we would
be able to like show this you know like
if you replace this for quantifications
here but maybe you can get something
closed yeah so if we can consider like a
conditional version of KT which like uh
as mentioned is already like empty
complete then if we can make like this
step work then it would be great it's
like also another approach it was like
excluding tests
um more like a very high level is like a
meta compressive like different like
method of his problems so like there's
like inter interview there should be
like a really close but
to like actually closing this Gap like
it recalls like a really breakthrough I
didn't say one time oh yes okay to be a
story is like it pink is like even like
a string and you find would you want to
find like the shortest program that
outputs the string and can you start
like I gave you a string with like some
stars like in this string and if I put a
star on some position it just means like
I don't care like what what your output
on this position and so you can also you
can you can also Define like the
shortest program produced like a
restricted and like shoes so that if if
you can say this version is going to be
like a MP complex yes so yeah okay
yeah like yeah it covers like a like
basically all these Notions and MCS to
start doing machines like they're off
like yeah
like in the Stars
the true personal is just in terms
Destiny to remove the star
uniform
ition and with the input here it's just
saying give me one tuning machine are
they like actually very difficult CSP
I'm talking about pptp
is
and probably Heroes result probably
works for he also right so that wouldn't
be surprising if you could extend the
insurance
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and other things
maybe you'll get an email